Ray Romano reacts to vinyls cancellation
it's bittersweet because I'm so glad
that I got to play that role the king of
rock and roll is singing about lettuce
okay
take it easy champ that's Ray Romano as
Zak on HBO's vinyl the series was picked
up for a second season in February but
on Wednesday
HBO execs decided to cancel it I
understand the 58 year old actor opened
up to et just hours after hearing the
news while promoting his new film ice
age collision course I found out this
morning always put makeup on it's
bittersweet cuz I'm so glad that I got
to play that role and you know try to
stretch and go to those places so I'm
happy I'm happy was there and who knows
there's a lot of different networks out
there and when it comes to emmy
nominations romano isn't too concerned
but did get a sweet endorsement from his
ice age co-star Queen Latifah you just
let it go you you know you you can't
help hearing things here and there I
don't believe that till I see it well
you should definitely be nominee
engrafted
you